Transcriptor: Tanya Wade
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Yo soy periodista así que
me gusta mucho hacer preguntas,
de forma que voy a empezar con una.
¿Existen las razas?
¿Qué creéis?
(Risas)
Aquí hemos venido a colaborar.
Esto es entre dos.
Sí. Sí, no, decís de todo, ¿no?
Pues esto es un poco
lo que yo quiero contaros
a lo largo de esta charla.
La primera pregunta
que tengo para vosotros es:
¿Tenéis móvil?
(¡Sí!)
Vale, que levante la mano
la gente que tiene móvil.
Estáis esclavizados.
Y ahora que levanten la mano
las personas que tienen Whatsapp.
Pues eso, que estáis esclavizados.
Ahora que levanten la mano
las personas a las que
no les ha llegado esta imagen,
a la que se conoce como
el negro del Whatsapp.
2, 3, 4, 5 personas a las que
no les ha llegado,
6, 7... en fin.
A la mayoría os ha llegado esta imagen.
¿Por qué? Porque se hizo viral.
Tanto es así que incluso nos llegaron
felicitaciones de Navidad,
"Christmas" con un rey Baltasar
transformado en el negro del Whatsapp.
(Risas)
Es más,
incluso hay disfraces
del negro del Whatsapp.
Ese señor que lleva un sombrero,
tiene un pene sobredimensionado
que le llega prácticamente a los pies
y que como atuendo
únicamente lleva una toalla.
Pues bien, para mí el tema
del disfraz del negro del Whatsapp,
de ver a tantísimas personas
en los carnavales
disfrazadas de negro, me hizo pensar
que quizá podría hablar de los disfraces.
Os animo a que saquéis esos móviles
que sé que todos tenéis
para empezar a jugar.
Por ejemplo:
¿qué sale cuando ponéis
"disfraz de negro"?
Yo he escogido ...
- no voy a esperaros eh,
que tengo sólo 18 minutos -
yo he escogido un par de los ejemplos
que salen cuando pones "negro",
y uno de ellos, pues redunda
un poco en este estereotipo
del pene sobredimensionado.
Y el otro, pues para seguir con los
estereotipos asociados
a las personas de raza negra,
además, por si no fuera suficiente,
lleva una lanza.
Pero, ¿qué sucede cuando
al estereotipo de raza
le asociamos además el tema del género?
Pues lo que sucede, es esto.
La primera en Google ponía:
"negra culona",
mientras que una lleva una lanza
la otra lleva un plumero.
Un disfraz.
¿Los disfraces son inocuos?,
¿sí o no?. No lo sé.
Vamos a ir avanzando.
¿Qué pasa cuando ponéis en vuestros
móviles y en vuestros buscadores,
las palabras "disfraz de árabe".
Buscad si queréis.
Cuando lo buscáis, lo que sale,
entre otras cosas,
son estos dos modelos.
Un hombre cubierto hasta los pies
y con una barba gigantesca
que le cubre toda la cara.
Y una mujer en cambio a la que
no le cubren prácticamente nada.
¿Y qué pasa cuando ponemos
"gitano" o "gitana"?
Pues exactamente lo mismo.
Un disfraz, una construcción.
Y en el caso de las mujeres,
una construcción pero con menos ropa.
Sin embargo, ¿qué creéis que pasa
cuando ponéis "disfraz de blanco"?
Efectivamente, alguien lo ha dicho:
"Que no hay".
Si ponéis disfraz de blanco, y además
incluyo los pantallazos de Google,
aparece un religioso, un marinero,
un camarero o una camarera.
No hay un disfraz de blanco.
¿Sabéis por qué?
Porque no existe una construcción con
respecto a las personas de raza blanca.
Porque las construcciones parten
de una parte del mundo
que define como es el resto del mundo.
Y eso, evidentemente, tiene consecuencias.
Hay personas que dirán:
"Pero bueno, existe también
un disfraz de español,
un disfraz de egipcio,
un disfraz de mexicano".
No es lo mismo.
La raza no es una nacionalidad.
De hecho, hay muchas personas que
estamos cansadas de que nos digan
que si somos españoles.
"Cómo vamos a ser
españoles si somos negros, ¿no?".
A veces hay una racialización
de la nacionalidad,
pero en este caso, como veis,
a lo que alude sobre todo,
a veces con poco acierto la verdad,
es a elementos culturales
de un país o de una nación.
Las razas no existen, es así.
Desde un punto de vista biológico,
y este anuncio lo muestra muy bien,
todos somos exactamente
iguales por dentro.
Las razas no existen.
Pero cuando salimos a la calle,
nos encontramos con realidades diferentes.
Y no es lo mismo lo que vive mi madre,
una señora blanca de Segovia,
que lo que vive mi padre,
un señor negro de Guinea Ecuatorial.
Ni siquiera lo que vivimos
sus hijos, Sebastian y yo,
que tenemos experiencias diferentes
por el hecho de estar a mitad de camino,
y no ser tan negros.
De hecho, hace relativamente poco,
hicieron un estudio
que tenía como escenario
a la estación de autobuses de Granada.
Allí concluyeron que a las personas
negras les paraban hasta 42 veces más,
para pedirles los papeles,
que a las personas blancas.
Un estudio con la Policía Nacional,
llevado a cabo
por la Asociación Pro Derechos
Humanos de Andalucía,
y por la Universidad de Granada.
Así que, las razas,
esa construcción que se ha hecho
- socioeconómica porque al final, sí,
es una construcción social,
pero muchas veces para meterse
dinero en el bolsillo -
ha justificado inequidades históricas
de la talla, de la dudosa talla de hecho,
de la esclavitud.
Si os parece seguimos jugando
y seguimos haciendo preguntas.
Esos somos mi hermano y yo.
Como hablo de él dije: "Vamos a ponerlo".
No le perdonaré a mi madre, jamás,
ese babero del vestido, pero bueno ...
Eran los 80 y es lo que había.
Juguemos a: "De mayor, quería ser".
Cuando era pequeña,
de mayor quería ser princesa.
Porque claro, no es una cosa rara, ¿no?
Ahora se me ha quitado.
Pero de pequeña yo quería ser princesa.
¿Y cómo creen que eran las princesas?
¿Cómo se las imaginan?
¡Blancas!
Blancas todas menos Pocahontas,
que tuvieron ese detalle.
Ahora sí, ahora hay más.
Ahora también está Tiana y tal.
Pero hay una de cada.
Tengo anécdotas prácticamente
con respecto a todo.
Yo era buena estudiante, así que
casi siempre por sacar buenas notas
era la "prota" en las obras de teatro.
Y lo llevaba fatal porque
no voy bien de memoria.
El caso es que, llegó un año
en el tocó Blancanieves.
(Risas)
Y mi profesora me dijo que no podía ser
Blancanieves, en todo caso Negracarbón
pero finalmente de lo que
hice fue de bruja.
Y no de la madrastra guapa
que se mira al espejo. No, no, no.
Fui bruja.
No podía ser Blancanieves,
no podía ser la princesa,
pero sí podía ser la bruja.
Con el tiempo decidí que
lo de princesa no, ya lo vi claro,
así que, como siempre
me ha gustado mucho leer,
pues pensé que podría ser escritora.
Pero ¿cómo creen que eran las escritoras?
Venga. A ver ...
Pues ya lo digo yo.
Si ponéis en Google la palabra
escritora esto es lo que sale.
Eran mujeres, blancas.
En vista de lo cual decidí que quizá,
debía apuntar a otro tipo de cosas
y dije, bueno, periodista.
Que eran ¿Cómo?
(Blancas)
¡Vaya! Habéis acertado.
Así las cosas, empecé a enterrar mi listón
y me conformé con ser una mujer feliz
que eran ...
(Blancas)
y trabajadora, que eran ...
¡En fin! Estaba complicada la cosa.
Me di cuenta que para ser,
tenía que ser blanca,
o directamente asumir
que no tenía derecho a soñar.
El caso es que ahora soy periodista, sí.
Y he escrito un libro también,
pero ha costado mucho.
Ha costado mucho
porque existe una construcción
- mucha culpa de eso la tienen los medios
de comunicación en los cuales trabajo,
y que adoro por otro lado, pero
tienen muchísima responsabilidad -
según la cual las personas negras sólo
aparecen de una manera muy determinada,
muy concreta y muy desagradable
en los medios de comunicación,
que es encaramados a una valla
que les desgarra la piel,
o bien en unas pateras,
prácticamente sin cara, difuminados.
Pero cuando se trata de mujeres,
ni siquiera tienen derecho a tener rostro,
a menos que estén embarazadas,
o a menos que suceda un desgracia.
Como la que se puede leer ahí:
"Mueren siete mujeres tras bloquear
la Guardia Civil la patera en la que iban"
¡Ahí sí! Tuvieron cara e incluso nombre.
Otra manera convencional
es la hipersexualización,
ahí tenemos a las Cacao Maravillao,
yo crecí con ellas.
Las personas de más de cierta edad,
que serán unos cuantos,
sabrán de quien hablo,
en los albores de Telecinco.
Y de eso no se libran tampoco los varones,
ya hemos visto al negro de Whatsapp,
pero aquí podemos ver "El mayor
desfase visto en Adán y Eva:
una mujer no es completa
hasta que un negro no se la meta".
Esto en un programa de televisión,
y ahondando de nuevo en esos tópicos,
por los cuales las personas negras
tienen unas propiedades sexuales que ...
En fin, ¡desmiento!
(Risas)
Por otro lado, otra forma común
de representación es la modernidad.
¡No nos sacan nunca!
Pero cuando nos sacan es
para que veáis que tenemos de todo.
"Fijaos que modernos somos".
Y oye, las hay que somos modernas,
pero no todas las personas negras lo son.
Ni es moderno ser negro,
ni es moderno mostrar la realidad,
porque lo que sucede
en la calle es eso, diversidad.
Y basta con ir a colegios públicos,
probablemente también aquí
pero sobre todo en las grandes ciudades,
para darse cuenta de que las personas
no tienen solo un color.
Por supuesto, en el deporte,
ahí sí salimos.
Que si medallas, que si podios,
ahí sí que tenemos espacio.
Luego a veces se habla del humor
para justificar determinadas cosas.
Claro que, ¡a ver a quién le hace gracia!
Ahí tengo el recorte de
una revista digital que se titula
"Manual para distinguir a la novia de
Mario Casas, Hugo Silva y Victor Clavijo".
Mujeres sin nombre,
porque sólo son "novias de" o "mujeres de"
Y por otro lado se trataba de una especie
de tratado de antropología del siglo XIX,
por el cual nos daban pistas,
como un pelo mas rizado
un labio más grueso, o una piel
un poco más o menos oscura,
para poder distinguir a mujeres
que claramente no son iguales.
Esta es bastante interesante.
Y además animo a que todos
reflexionemos ahora.
Que es la evolución
de la hucha del Domund,
por la cual jibarizaban cabezas
de personas del sur del mundo,
del sur global, para pedir dinero.
Las agitaban: "Esto es dinero para
los pobres niños de África".
Con el paso del tiempo
la cosa fue evolucionando,
porque evidentemente eso
ya no tenía mucho sentido,
lanzar ahí a los niños
a la calle a que pidieran.
Y empezaron a utilizar a menores
con barrigas hinchadas y moscas alrededor,
para dar pena y que las personas donasen.
Esas imágenes se daban, por supuesto.
Pero estaban vulnerando la posibilidad
de que esos niños pudieran olvidar.
Esto es más contemporáneo, es de 2017.
Ahí tenemos a un niño llamado Hope,
desnudo, desnutrido, sucio.
Al que una mano blanca está dando
una botellita de agua
para que pueda salvarse.
Pasa el tiempo, Hope cumple 1 año
y ya sonríe, ya está fenomenal.
Hope no va a poder olvidarse nunca
de ese episodio tan terrible de su vida.
No van a permitirle que lo olvide porque
está por todo el mundo gracias a Internet.
Eso es peligroso y además genera
que vayamos cubriendo de capas,
de sedimentos, de prejuicios,
nuestro cerebro.
Es imposible que no sea así.
Cuando vais a África,
o algún lugar del sur
y os hacéis una foto con esos niños
a los que rara vez se pide permiso,
o por lo menos a los padres
como sí hacemos cuando estamos aquí,
la lectura que se hace
en Facebook es: "¡Qué solidario!".
Pero si mi padre va a Suiza o a Suecia
y se hace fotos con niños blancos
pensarán que o es un cuentacuento
o le denunciarán.
Todos los niños tienen derecho
a que se proteja su intimidad, todos.
Y yo diría que especialmente
en esos momentos de sus vidas.
Eso ha generado discursos, como que Mariló
dijera en un programa con mucha audiencia:
"Esto no es como los negritos, que
vamos a darles dinero, quiero lo mío".
O Paz Padilla: "Me han sorprendido
los negros por ser supertrabajadores
y superhonestos".
Bah, ¡gracias!
Por otro lado, que se utilice
la nacionalidad de las personas
cuando es algo que se estudia
en periodismo, no es importante.
Y aparte, de nuevo,
y como decía anteriormente
acaba construyendo los prejuicios,
que al final nos perjudican cada día.
Y algo bastante común es que nos
pregunten únicamente sobre el racismo,
como si no pudiéramos
hablar de nada más,
y créanme, yo he visto Got Talent,
por ejemplo, este año.
Puedo hablar de eso,
y puedo hablar de muchísimas otras cosas.
Somos personas diversas
que tenemos una opinión.
Esto, finalmente, tiene consecuencias.
Y es el vídeo que vamos
a ver a continuación.
Forma parte del canal
que tengo en YouTube
llamado "Nadie nos ha dado vela
en este entierro"
en el que interrogo a personas acerca
de la construcción identitaria,
de qué elementos han hecho,
qué ladrillos han provocado
que hoy sean quienes son.
(Vídeo)
Para mucha gente es España es incompatible
la españolaridad con la negritud.
Para mí no.
Empece a sentirme africano al ver que
cuando me mandaban a mi casa
a pesar de nacer en Torrejón,
querían decir que me fuera a África.
Conceptos tan cerrados como patria
o nación a mí me limitan personalmente.
Y me limitan cultural e intelectualmente.
Lo deseable sería que empezáramos
a olvidarnos de banderas,
porque las banderas son lo que iba delante
en las guerras que quisimos dejar atrás.
Los medios de comunicación
son la estereotipación.
Nos están reforzando la posición de
dominio de las personas leuco-europeas.
He asumido algunos de los estereotipos
y a veces me he descubierto a mí misma
con ciertos comportamientos
infravalorativos hacia otras personas.
Te llaman negro en el colegio
y te das cuenta y dices:
"Sí, soy negro, pero ¿y eso es malo?".
Empiezas a asociarlo
con una serie de cosas.
Creo que voy a estar toda mi vida buscando
un lugar en el mundo en el que sentir
que formo parte de él,
y no lo voy a encontrar.
Si eres un español blanco, heterosexual,
de clase media o alta
que no has salido de las cuatro paredes
que consideras que son España
en tu puñetera vida,
o sólo lo has hecho de vacaciones,
la identidad no es importante, seguramente
Tenemos que organizarnos
de algún modo y decir:
"Señores, estamos aquí".
(Fin vídeo)
Pues yo diría que estamos
y que somos de aquí.
¿Qué les parece si jugamos a hacerlo real?
(Aplausos)